et puis cette information qui confirme
la capture des partisans de chasse aux
coûts qui voulait prendre le palais
présidentiel
c'est donc la radio romaine qui vient de
donner cette information un changement
de régime qui s'est donc déroulée dans
le sang contrairement aux autres pays de
l'est a une fois de plus c'est la
télévision qui a joué un rôle capital en
direct pendant plus de trois heures
des millions de roumains ont assisté au
soulèvement du peuple de bucarest
le récit de cette révolution tragique
jean-marc ils osent tout d'abord un
studio étriqué une atmosphère de
réunions syndicales
une petite foule qui se bousculent
maladroitement autour d'un micro et d'un
drop et pourtant c'est de ce studio de
la télévision roumaine que jailliront
après quarante deux ans de communisme
les premiers mots et les premières
images de liberté écoutez ne dit que la
roumanie socialiste dit la roumanie dans
les rues de bucarest les roumains n'en
croient pas leurs oreilles
la radio officielle vient de tomber et
c'est par la voix de mme hirsch et à
dinescu poète et surtout opposant
célèbre qu'ils apprennent que nicolae
ceausescu le tir ont détesté vient de
quitter le pouvoir
déjà une source diplomatique occidentale
affirme que l'ancien ministre déchu
cornelio manescu 63 ans aurait pris le
pouvoir à la tête d'un front de salut
national non armés ont ensuite atteint
premières images de citoyens anonymes de
roumains sans leur jeûne et de crise de
parole libre
les visages se connecte à cannes watch
soyons vigilants attention les hommes de
la milice sont encore partout ceausescu
a plus d'un tour dans son sac
soyons prudents nous ne savons pas
toujours où il est né ou rôles nationale
mais le miracle est déjà là dans les
milliers de voix qui n'ont pas oublié le
vieil hymne national roumain
rien n'est vraiment réglé mais qui l'on
sait déjà que grâce à une partie de
l'armée favorables aux manifestants les
terribles miliciens de la securitate et
eau pour l'instant céder le terrain dans
le centre de la capitale et on chante
malgré les rumeurs d'une contre attaque
des partisans de l'ancien dictateur en
direction des locaux de la télévision
qui continue à parler au pays et au
monde et avec la nuit la liberté
naissante tombe en direct à la
télévision roumaine incroyable au siège
de l'ex comité central dans l'ancien
palais royal ils sont des centaines de
milliers à écouter les proclamations du
nouveau coach national où la rebelle
s'adresser à la foule le premier orateur
n'utilise pas le terme tovaritch
camarades mais fera si laure mes frères
et s'est immédiatement le délire
et puis sans transition arrive au balcon
un petit homme qui annonce qu'il est
sorti de prison voilà une heure à peine
c'est dimitri madilu diplomate roumain
des nations unies incarcéré pour avoir
osé rédiger un vrai rapport sur les
droits de l'homme en roumanie
il avait disparu depuis tous les
orateurs il va appeler à la prudence au
calme dire non à la vengeance oui à la
modération à la télévision le défilé des
dernières victimes connues de 25 ans de
police politique continue ici pic st
loup mais outre la romaine y est
omniprésente
dehors l'histoire sanglante de la
roumanie est encore en marche
elle n'a fait pour l'instant qu'un trou
dans le drapeau roumain un drapeau ou
les symboles du pouvoir communiste ont
été systématiquement arrachés
c'est un bide je vous propose cette fois
d'écouter le témoignage d'un français
qui a assisté aux événements de la
matinée il est rentré ce soir de
bucarest témoignages recueillis par
alliance berger il y avait les chars qui
tourne autour de la place qui de temps
en temps s'arrêtait qui est qu'ils
tiraient qui tirait sans discontinuer
dans la foule sur tout ce qui bouge ou
sur tout ce qui bougeait une fois que la
place a été nettoyée si on peut dire une
fois que la place a été vidée des gens
sont partis quand même des camions sont
arrivés on a chargé les gens dans les
camions les emmener comment vous vous
avez vécu tout ça ce matin quand vous
avez quitté l'ambassade
ce matin c'était l'émotion parce que
bucarest était en train de tomber aux
mains des manifestants
et on est sorti donc avec les mets
drapeau bleu blanc rouge à la portière
et c'était très émouvant en tunnel nous
acclamer tout le monde faisait lé v de
la victoire et c'était j'ai pleuré j'ai
pleuré parce que on sentait que c'était
25 ans de le misère 25 à 25 ans de
souffrance qui qui d'un seul coup exposé
c'était vraiment quelque chose
d'extraordinaire